dieses ganz normale Big Mac Menü kostet
9,99 € und dieses hier drüben kostet
über 100 € weil wir daran alles selbst
gemacht haben und jede einzelne Zutat
optimiert haben finden wir heraus ob
sich das Ganze lohnt aber erstmal müssen
wir uns an den Geschmack vom Big Mac
Menü erinnern deshalb habe ich mir eins
besorgt schauen wir mal was dazu gehört
selbstverständlich kommt das Big Mac
Menü mit einem Big Mac hier drin ist
eine Cola Zero für mich die richtige
Entscheidung und ansonsten halten wir
simpel ein paar Pommes mit ein bisschen
Salat und diesmal wurde sogar die Soße
nicht vergessen für mich ist es ganz
klar Mayonnaise 9,99 € kostet dieser
Spaß hier mittlerweile Inflation hört
auch bei McDonald's nicht auf aber so
schlecht wie es vielleicht sein mag für
den Körper so gut kann es manchmal tun
ich meine das ist so der Inbegriff von
comfort food das ist wahrscheinlich der
bekannteste Burger der Welt und nicht
nur der Big Mac ist geil sondern auch
die Pommes und ihr habt ja heute schon
gehört heute finden wir heraus ob das
Ganze besser wird wenn wir einfach
schlum gesagt Geld drauf schmeißen also
wenn wir die krassesten Premium Zutaten
benutzen um dieses ikonische Menü auf
ein neues Level zu heben ich weiß nicht
Eric was sagst du das ist schon einfach
ein Ding das gibt's seit keine Ahnung
wie viel Jahren und das wird es auch
wahrscheinlich noch 50 Jahre geben das
ist einfach eine Ikone so ein bisschen
dieser dieser Big Mac McDonald's pomis
kann man eigentlich auch nicht haten ne
dünn knusprig und wir haben ja schon mal
probiert das Ganze selbst zu machen sind
mehr oder weniger gefilt aber heute
machen wir es nicht einfach selbst
sondern wir probieren wirklich einfach
das ganze auf ein neues Level zu heben
und einfach so teuer wie möglich zu
machen ich schnappe mir hier einmal den
Big Mac also es ist natürlich kein
krasser Burger aber wir wollen uns in
den ungefähren Linien von diesem
ikonischen Menü bewegen und einfach
probieren oh budgetbegrenzung ist so
krass wie möglich zu machen deshalb
sollten wir jetzt einkaufen gehen und
hier befindet sich unsere Ausbeute wir
sind durch jegliche Feinkostläden
biosupmärkte und fachhändel gelaufen und
haben das hier besorgt ich sag euch
einfach mal was wir hier haben und was
das jeweils so ungefähr kostet
klassischer Bio eisbecksalat 250 die
teuerste Ketchup die wir finden konnten
ebenfalls 250 teure Ketchup gibt's gar
nicht so häufig kleiner funf burgerkäse
150 japanische Mario für 7 € die Jan 4 €
Corny Chance 5 € hier unten versteckt
haben wir etwas mehralz mit dem wir
unsere Pommes salizen 15 € französische
Zwiebeln für 7 € 5 € Kartoffeln
natürlich ein Steak welches wir gleich
Wolfen um ptis zu formen für fast 30 €
und ihr fragt euch vielleicht warum hat
der Typ eine McDonald's Tüte wenn er
etwas von McDonald's nachmacht ihr seht
vielleicht wir haben hier kein burgerban
ich habe gefragt kann ich vielleicht
einfach ein Big Mac Ban haben leider
nein hier drin befindet sich aber eins
wie habe ich das jetzt bekommen ein Big
Mac Bann Sowi die pommesverpackung und
leerer Becher hat mich so viel gekostet
wie ein Big macmenü 9,9 und alles in
allem sind wir bei ungefähr 85 € mit
diesem Einkauf also was auch immer wir
jetzt hier raus erschaffen sollte besser
richtig lecker sein wenn wir wie heute
diese teuren Zutaten verwenden dann muss
ich diese natürlich kaufen und im
Durchschnitt gebe ich bei einem Video
über 1000 € aus also für alles was dazu
gehört und im letzten Jahr habe ich 52
Videos gemacht alles in allem ist das
schon eine ganze Menge damit ich alles
im Blick behalte nutze ich auch privat
finanzguru und ihr könnt mit dem Code
Max 24 finanzguru plus 3 Monate
kostenlos testen und das beste ist
gemeinsam mit finanzguru verlosen wir
ein Jahr finanzguru plus unter drei
Leuten die sich mit dem Code anmelden
finanzguru kennt ihr vielleicht von
finanzfluss oder von die Höhle der Löwen
mittlerweile hat finanzgur über 1,5
Millionen Nutzer und die App an sich ist
komplett kostenfrei wenn du dich
anmeldest erhälst du einen Überblick
über all deine Finanzen du kannst dein
Depot deine kryptobörse deine Konten
deine Kreditkarte alles mit finanzguru
verbinden alle Einnahmen und Ausgaben
werden automatisch kategorisiert und
übersichtlich in der App aufbereitet zu
zeigt dir die App alle Verträge die du
hast übersichtlich an überflüssige
Verträge können mit einem Fingertipp
recht sicher gekündigt werden mit
finanzguru plus erhaltet ihr für nur
2,99 € im Monat Zugriff auf eine Fülle
von Funktionen die euer Geldmanagement
auf ein ganz neues Level heben und wie
gesagt könnt ihr mit dem Code Max 24
finanzguru plus 3 Monate lang kostenlos
testen den Code könnt ihr in der App
einfach unter dem Reiter mehr einlösen
mit finanzguru plus erhältst du
intelligente budgetvorschläge die dir
eine klare Übersicht über
Ausgabenkategorien wie Shopping
Lebensmittel oder tanken geben du kannst
tiefgehende Analysen nutzen dein
Kaufverhalten und die Entwicklung deines
Vermögens bequem in der App beobachten
lade dir also unter diesem QR Code die
App herunter und werde 2024 zum Chef
deiner Finanzen weiter geht's mit dem
Video eine Sache habe ich allerdings
noch als Ergänzung wir haben etwas
bestellt das ist leider noch nicht da
wir wollten die Pommes in wagufett
frittieren und haben dafür 3 kg wagufett
für 40 € bestellt aber das sollte schon
seit drei Tagen da sein kommt nicht
deshalb vielleicht kommt es während des
Drehs so sind wir bei ungefähr 85 €
fangen wir einfach mal an zu kochen weil
ich bin echt gespannt ob sich der ganze
Aufwand lohnt ich habe ein paar der
Kartoffeln jetzt mal gewaschen
anschließend werden wir sie auch schon
schälen wie bei McDonald's dann habe ich
mir schon was überlegt wie wir gleich
diese perfekte McDonald's Form
hinbekommen ich habe da so eine
Gerätschaft die wird das perfekt für uns
Regeln ich habe hier meine Mandoline das
kennt ihr vielleicht damit schneide ich
immer mal wieder Sachen ganz fein aber
eine Besonderheit habe ich hier
eingesetzt und zwar kann man hier so
klingen reinmachen und zufälligerweise
ist das finde ich der perfekte Abstand
die perfekte Breite wie bei McDonald's
Pommes man klippt das auf der Unterseite
ein dann stellt man die wünschte Höhe
ein und auf der größten Stufe sieht das
für mich verdächtig nach dem perfekten
meces pommesformat aus ich habe
jahrelang rum experimentiert jetzt
finden wir heraus ob sie auch wirklich
so werden wie sie sollen also glaub wir
sind auf dem guten Weg schauen wir
einmal rein let's go oh mein Gott first
try ich finde das ist perfekt McDonald's
Pommes Format weil sonst sind die immer
zu dick wenn man zu Hause Pommes macht
aber das hier so kennt und so liebt man
noch die McDonald's Pommes geil
schneiden wir ein paar Kartoffeln so und
hier haben wir sie jetzt was wir jetzt
machen ziemlich simpel wir geben die
Kartoffeln einfach in eine Schale mit
kaltem Wasser s dass die Stärke ein
bisschen auswaschen kann jetzt brauchen
wir ein bisschen Geduld ein wenig später
ich bin ehrlich ich hat nicht so viel
Geduld nehmen wir uns unsere Pommes aus
dem mittlerweile stärkehaltigen Wasser
raus und legen sie auf ein Tuch um sie
gut abzutrocknen die trocknen wir jetzt
richtig gut ab ihr seht hier habe ich
schon die Fritteuse bereitgestellt weil
nasse Kartoffeln sollte man auf keinen
Fall eine frituse geben wenn die jetzt
gut werden wenn die werden wie bei Meck
ist mache ich sie glaube ich nie wieder
anders es wird glaube ich am Ende side
by side richtig richtig gut aussehen
unsere Fritöse ist vorgeheizt die sollte
ungefähr 120° haben wenn wir
vorfrittieren wir sind jetzt gerade
121° perfekt das heißt wir können die
Kartoffeln reinschmeißen vorfrittieren
und nach ungefähr 3 Minuten wieder
rausholen laden wir mal unsere
Kartoffeln rein jetzt wollen wir keine
Farbe dran bekommen kein nichts wir
wollen einmal dass die Oberfläche so
leicht anfrittiert wird denn dann machen
wir damit etwas was man vielleicht nicht
erwarten würde also ab ins Öl ca 5
Minuten später sind die Pommes
vorfrittiert sie haben noch keine Farbe
bekommen aber genauso ist es richtig wir
lassen sie gut abtropfen wenn sie
abgetropft sind geben wir sie auf ein
Tablett mit zever und trocknen das Öl ab
die sind jetzt echt schon relativ weich
geworden das heißt am Ende geht's nur
noch darum eine knusprige Außenschicht
wiederherzustellen sodass wir sie innen
weich und außen knusprig haben und wenn
es nicht klappt dann ich mach's auch
gerade zum ersten Mal wir haben jetzt
ein paar Pommes vorfrittiert von diesem
Blech die gerade alle noch aufeinander
häen und die gute Nachricht ist sie
hängen komplett wieder auseinander sind
schön knusprig dass sie ein bisschen
abtropfen und dann machen wir einfach
mal einen kleinen Taste test was mich
aber viel mehr freut ist dass dieses
Paket hier vorne angekommen ist denn
darin findet sich das wagu Fett es ist
wirklich mitten im Dreh gerade
angekommen wir warten seit Tagen drauf
stand jeden Tag da dass es auch kommen
sollte es kam aber nicht und wenn das
hier jetzt gut schmeckt kann ich mir nur
vorstellen wie viel geiler es noch
schmecken wird wenn wir das in wagu Fett
frittieren kümmern wir uns jetzt um die
Big Mac Soße und bevor einige von euch
in die Kommentare Rennen und sagen da
gehört gar keine Ketchup rein ich habe
es mal so gemacht und es schmeckt für
mich eins zu eins und das ist was ich
heute schaffen will deshalb rein mit der
Ketchup das mache ich ein bisschen nach
Gefühl weil man kann es einfach
nachjustieren da gibt man ein bisschen
mehr Mayo bisschen mehr was auch immer
dazu bis zur gewünschten Konsistenz
neben Ketchup geen wir etwas Mayonnaise
dazu auch hier natürlich schon die teure
cupi Mayonnaise aus Japan für 7 € die
Flasche im Einsatz fühlt sich an wie ein
Babybauch und ist einfach das beste was
man kaufen kann Senf nicht irgendeiner
diejan Senf der ist ein bisschen
potenter als so ein normaler Senf
deshalb geen wir nicht ganz so viel
davon rein so viel etwa das ist die
beste Ketchup die man mit Geld kaufen
kann nehmen uns ein Messer öffnen ein
Glas Cornichons im Prinzip teurere
Gürkchen geben schon mal einen kleinen
Schluck vom Gurkenwasser er mit in die
Schüssel dann picken wir uns ein paar
corn raus also ich finde das ist eine
normale Größe für eineürkel testen wir
die Qualität Crunch Säure sehr lecker
die schneiden wir in kleine Stückchen
und geben Sie anschließend zu unseren
restlichen Zutaten wir sind schon fast
da eine Prise von unserem 15 € Salz darf
nicht fehlen wobei ich sagen muss das
ist auch wirklich sehr sehr geil ich war
nämlich bei den Salinen wo das
hergestellt ist mal oder zwei od dre dre
soll ich mal probieren wie es schmeckt
ich bild mir halt wirklich ein dass es
nach mehr schmeckt also ist ja mehr Salz
und es ist so wie wenn man ausvsehen mal
in der Nordsee so den Mund aufmacht und
dann so dieses diesen salzigen Geschmack
hinten im Rachen hat ich mag es außerdem
darf nicht fehlen ein Teelöffel
Zwiebelpulver das
Knoblauchpulver Knoblauchpulver und ein
Teelöffel Knoblauchpulver kN das ist
Zwiebelpulver ein Teelöffel steing
gewordenes Knoblauchpulver gehen wir
dazu für mich ne wenn ich keine echte
bigmc Soße neben dran habe ist das die
perfekte Farbe jetzt muss nur der
Geschmackstest überzeugen probieren wir
einmal unsere selbstgemachte Big Mac
Soße boah das ist echt durch diese
Einzelzutaten ne schmeckt so wie eine
viel geschmacksintensivere Big Mac Soße
es verändert den Geschmack ein bisschen
bin ich ganz ehrlich es ist nicht eins
zu eins aber die Ansätze sind da und
dann schmeckt einfach viel intensiver
bin gespannt wie das auf dem Burger
performt eine Sache die auf jeden Fall
überzeugen wird ist das Beef weil das
ist einfach viel besser als bei
McDonald's ich meine dieses Steak hier
kostet fast 30 € wir haben ein schönes
recod und das werden wir jetzt in
Streifen schneiden und Wolfen ich habe
das gerade noch mal in den
Gefrierschrank gelegt damit es schön
runterkt in der Temperatur das wird
immer wieder empfohlen dass man beim
Wolfen das Fleisch davor ein bisschen
runterkühlt damit man so das
bestmögliche Produkt hat holen wir unser
Steak raus und es tut ein bisschen in
der Seele weh wir hatten kurz überlegt
ob wir ein vagio Steak dafür kaufen
sollen klar das hätte es noch teurer
gemacht aber wir wollten so ein
Kompromiss aus teuer und wirklich auch
sinnvoll weil das hier wird ein brutales
Burger Petty ergeben einfach in Streifen
schneiden diese diese Marmorierung ne
ist einfach wunderschön wunder
wunderschön und dann können wir diese
Streifen gleich in unseren Fleischwolf
füttern nehmen wir uns einen Streifen
von unserem Steak und geben ihn in
unseren Fleischwolf eine Sache die wir
bei den Goldies Jungs gelernt haben ist
dass man tatsächlich die feinste Stufe
beim Wolfen nehmen sollte weil das das
Burger Petty schön zusammenhält und wenn
man es zu grob macht dann fällt es
auseinander boah wie fettig ne wie
fettig dieses schöne Stück Fleisch war
unser Steak hatte 320 g das ergibt
natürlich mehr als zwei petties wenn man
die maces Größe übernimmt wir gucken
aber dass wir zwei ordentliche petties
auf unserem eigenen Big Mac bekommen die
Spannung steigt ihr seht es ist alles
vorbereitet und ich werde jetzt zunächst
einmal unser temperiertes wagu Fett das
hatten wir die ganze Zeit in warm Wasser
liegen in einen Topf gießen weil darin
werden wir gleich Frittieren falls ihr
euch wundert wir können es natürlich
nicht in der frituse machen weil eine
ganze frituse mit wagofett zu füllen das
hätte das wäre ein bisschen außer
Verhältnis gewesen also rein in den Topf
wow
wow ein letzter blop war noch drin
perfekte Menge um so eine Handvoll
Pommes zu frittieren das lassen wir
jetzt auf Temperatur kommen hier haben
wir alles bereitgestellt einmal die
Verpackung für unsere Pommes dann
natürlich der Becher mit dem von allen
gehassten Deckel den werde ich aber zur
Seite tun ich hasse das ich finde es so
schlimm aber irgendwo macht es
wahrscheinlich auch Sinn dann Big Mac
Verpackung aus Papier selbstverständlich
innen drin das teuerste burgerbrot
meines Lebens ich glaube das das macht
so kleine Nuancen die einfach dann dem
Kopf suggerieren okay das ist gerade
McDonald's Burger aber vielleicht ist ja
einfach noch viel besser als die davor
falls ihr euch fragt was hier vor sich
hinbrutzelt wir haben einfach aus dem
Fleischwolf noch das letzte bisschen
Fett genommen das beim Wolfen hängen
geblieben ist und jetzt haben wir
natürlich eine wunderschöne Basis in der
wir jetzt anrösten können weil trocken
rösten sollte man das nie McDonald's
Haut glaube ich in Toaster aber die
Freiheit nehmen wir uns das vernünftig
auf Gusseisen anzurösten also burgerband
platzieren butzelt hier schon vor sich
hin so muss es sein untere Seite auch
das mittlere Band legen wir dazu und
röen wir natürlich auch von beiden
Seiten an und drück die Daumen dass es
am Ende schön aussieht das wagu Fett ist
jetzt auf Temperatur und der Duft der
davon aufsteigt ist wirklich so wie in
so einem mexikanischen tacoladen so
Steak Tacos das riecht richtig so nach
Steak fetttig Steak und ich glaube das
wird sich auf unsere Pommes übertragen
es gibt aber nur eine Art und Weise es
herauszufinden machen wir hier mal ein
paar auf die Schaumkelle und wir lassen
Sie einfach in unser wagioofett fallen
ohne vorzufritieren ohne alles nach und
nach behalten dabei ein Blick dass es
nicht überkocht und dann gucken wir
einfach mal wie das wird wir können ja
nach und nach unsere pommestüte füllen
ich würde sagen das hier geht gerade
noch so als meces Farbe durch oder kein
Spaß Freunde diese Pommes sind verdammt
gut aber hier drin hab hab wir ein paar
tiefkühlpommes im vagu Fett frittiert
und das ist das krasse die schwimmen
hier bestimmt dreimal so lang drin wie
unsere kleinen Pommes drin waren und
trotzdem sind sie noch schön goldgelb
noch nicht so bräunlich die hier sind so
weiß aber das was wir hier haben ist
wirklich besser als eine McDonald's
Pommes ihr fragt euch jetzt warum es
sieht genauso aus gleiche geile Form
aber ist knusprig und hat einfach hinten
raus Bagu Geschmack das ist so krank
diese Pommes schmecken nach wagum
gewonnen OP wir können sogar immer noch
2 D Minuten drin bleiben wir uns um
unsere Burger ich nehme einfach ein
bisschen was von dem wagu Fett und geb
das hier auf meine Panscher die ist
schon schön heiß und dann Formen wir uns
petties wir nehmen uns einfach mal ja so
eine gute Hand voll das sind
wahrscheinlich so 80 g und Form daraus
erstmal so ein Ball den wir dann einfach
in der Handfläche ein bisschen platt
drücken wollen jetzt kein smashed Burger
machen aber wir wollen ungefähr ein
gleichmäßig dickes Petty erzielen dass
wir natürlich gleich noch mit 15 € Salz
ein wenig wirürzen werden Nummer ein es
darf auch ein bisschen selfmate aussehen
oder und ihr seht da können wir noch ein
drittes Paty draus man könnte es jetzt
ganz genau nehmen und runterbrechen aber
es ist immer noch ein spaßvide also
nimmt nichts zu ernst was wir hier
machen machen wir ein paar Burger oder
von einer Seite ein bisschen seitzen und
ab geht's und drauf damit das schöne ist
das wird sich nicht so stark
zusammenziehen parallel POM es nehmen
gut abtropfen lassen dieser wagio Duft
erfüllt wirklich mittlerweile die ganze
Küche es ist unbeschreiblich rein in
unsere Schüssel also unsere Portion
Pommes ist fertig können wir einfüllen
wir haben auch diese Schaufeln halt ne
ja uns fehlt diese Schaufel ja aber wir
machen das einfach so komm sieht doch
gut aus ist eine große Pommes Farbe dran
so muss es sein kannst halt nicht
vergleichen mit McDonald's ne das machen
die halt nicht im Ansatz so wir haben
die Soße wir haben die Pommes wenn die
fertig sind müssen wir nur noch
anrichten nicht zu vergessen unsere Cola
1,3 Colas um genau zu sein weil eine
Flasche reicht nicht für uns ich fülle h
einmal ein da muss ich ehrlich sagen ich
liebe ja auch diese sirupcoha ne die wir
so Zapfen können so gucken wir mal guck
mal was hier an fett schwimmt wir haben
uns extra noch mal ein Big Mac besorgt
damit wir jetzt perfekt gleich aufbauen
können und dann können wir uns auch
schon ans zusammenbauen machen ganz
unten etwas Soße unsere also realalk
unsere Soße schppert die Big Mac Soße
komplett weg was so die
Geschmacksintensität angeht ne ein paar
rohe Zwiebeln etwas Salat und dann eine
einzige Scheibe Käse einmal oben drauf
damit die auch schön schmilzt folgt
direkt danach unser Petty perfekte Größe
für das Bann danach kommen nur noch mal
ein paar Zwiebeln drauf zack zack zack
und das war's jetzt die Mittelschicht
Boom drauf Soße Salat hier kommen
natürlich wieder unsere teuren
Minigurken zum Einsatz die schneide ich
ein bisschen seitlich s dass wir eine
größere Auflagefläche kriegen Zack und
dieses eine gurkenstück entspricht so
drei kleinen Stückchen von unserem
cornichon als nächstes ist wieder ein PY
dran das nehmen wir uns oben drauf damit
drück das schon mal so ein bisschen
zusammen hier dann folgen nur noch ein
paar gehackte Zwiebeln und wir krönen
den König das sieht jetzt halt wieder
aus wie ein Big Mac aus der
Werbung guck mal neben unseren Big Mac
sieht der originale big wirklich wieder
aus wie so der Bruder den keiner mag
aber jetzt würde ich sagen bauen wir
beides mal nebeneinander auf dann seht
ihr wirklich jeden noch so kleinen
[Musik]
Unterschied beantworten wir zunächst die
am wenigsten spannende Frage und zwar
welche Cola ist
besser Sirup Cola ist schon geil und
hier einmal die aus der Flasche weil mit
Sirup nachmachen hätte mir nicht gekonnt
krass wie unterschiedlich die schmeckt
ne die sirupca ist vor allem eins süßer
dadurch auch irgendwie geiler also der
Punkt geht auf jeden Fall an das
klassische Big Mac Menü kommen wir jetzt
zu den Pommes ich weiß nicht ob ihr ohne
es zu wissen sagen könntet welche maces
sind und welche nicht weil ich würde
fast denken dass man sagt die die besser
aussehen sind von McDonald's und das
sind aber unsere also für mich
persönlich sehen die auf jeden Fall eine
ganze Ecke besser aus ein klein bisschen
dicker sind sie jetzt am Ende geraten
aber nichtsdestotrotz überzeugen wir uns
vom Geschmack meces Pommes nicht
wabbelig steht gut dieser typische
Geschmack einfach ne trotzdem nicht
super knusprig aber irgendwie so dieser
positiv pappige Geschmack so
und trotzdem schmeck auch schonend
McDonald's das hier ist unsere eigene
Version eigene Pommes selbst frittiert
ich muss aber auch der fber eine Pommes
auf einmal testen auch unsere nicht
wbelig wir probieren ich muss nicht mal
einen zweiten Bissen nehmen also ohne
Witz ich weiß wie viele Leute diese
McDonald's Pommes lieben ne das ist viel
viel krasser knurpriger innen drin
cremiger und diese Nuance vom wagu
Geschmack vergiss bitte nicht sie ist
nicht nur krasser sie ist auch deutlich
deutlich teurer das stimmt ist auch viel
viel teurer aber guck mal so hoch
platziere ich dieses bigm Menü es ist
einfach so iconic dass ich eigentlich
davon ausgehe dass das nicht so gut sein
kann aber die Pommes ist wesentlich
besser nehmen wir eine komm die stehen
wirklich ungefähr gleich lang knusprig
gar nichts Unangenehmes dabei und dieser
leichte wagu Geschmack wunderschön wenn
man dazu jetzt noch eine 7 € mayio nimmt
ich glaube dann gibt's gar keinen
Zweifel mehr das kann einfach nur
gewinnen wir haben jetzt ja auf die TK
Pommes zurückgegriffen ein zwei Tage
experimentieren und wir kriegen das gena
so gut hin wir haben uns einfach ein
bisschen Zeit gespart krass dass das so
lecker ist aber vagio ist halt einfach
ein cheatcot bei einer Sache sind wir
uns glaube ich einig die mit Abstand
spannendste Frage stellt sich zwischen
diesen beiden Kompanen hier der
McDonald's Big Mac und der nicht ganz
McDonald's Big Mac bei dem wir das ein
oder andere vielleicht optimiert haben
wir haben uns ja heute morgen erst daran
erinnert wie er so schmeckt
aber natürlich kann man keinen garerlauf
erwarten im Petty dann schmeckt wirklich
vor allem die Soße aber es ist lecker es
ist wirklich lecker und jetzt kommt der
große Moment wir haben echt lange in der
Küche gestanden dafür das hier ist unser
selbstgemachter Big Mac die Röstaromen
am Paty ne die suchst du wirklich
vergebens beim echten Big Mac die Bands
sind wieder schön weich geworden dadurch
dass er jetzt auch ein bisschen
zusammengebaut war und ich glaube wenn
wir hier zusammendrücken ne wie war es
noch beimem guten Burger darf es auch
ein bisschen saften aber vor allem der
Geschmack muss uns überzeugen und
natürlich beantworten wir dann auch die
Frage ist es das ganze Wert also rein in
den Luxus Big
Mac so sieht ein bissanschnitt in der
Werbung aus alter Werbung ist das
perfekte Stichwort dieser Big Mac
schmeckt so wie das was man sich
vorstellt wenn man Werbung für einen Big
Mac sieht ist gigantisch du hast
ordentlich beef diese Soße braucht sich
gar nicht zu verstecken gegen die
meckessoße im Gegenteil es ist sogar gut
dass sie so kräftig ist weil so hat sie
eine Chance oder so kann sie auf einem
Podest mit diesem beef stehen es ist
eine Sensation schon fast finde ich mal
so ein so so ein so ein realen Big Mac
zu essen bin sehr sehr gespannt jetzt
dass ihr nicht denkt dass ich euch
komplett Verarsche das ist wirklich so
viel mehr als ein Big Mac und das krasse
ist jetzt auch wo ich dich reinbeißen
sehe sieht einfach genauso aus erste
Moment big ja ja und dann kommt ne aber
das Fleisch allein was du im Mund hast
danach das nicht nur Brot und Soße ja
das ist ein Burger halt ne das ist ein
Burger und das ist ein Big Mac wie er
sein sollte aber die Soße ist extrem gut
getrofen ja also ohne Witz Leute es wäre
schön wenn der echte Big Mac ein
bisschen mehr so wäre ihr könnt es euch
aber wahrscheinlich denken wenn es jetzt
nicht gerade in so einem lustigen
Experiment Video ist dann lohnt sich das
natürlich überhaupt nicht sich das für
100 € zu machen geiles Experiment hat
richtig Spaß gemacht das ganze heute
durchzutesten das stimmt wir haben
insgesamt haben wir gewonnen es schmeckt
besser als das bigm Menü und das wir was
heißen wir sehen uns beim nächsten Video
wieder bis dahin ciao
ciao